المقال حاضرا هنا في مارب بروحه وشعره
بعبارات تردد الخوف عار الصمت عار من نحن
عشاق النهار
تشرق شمس مارب مجددا في معرض ثاني للكتاب
وفي تظاهره ثقافيه ومعرفيه تؤكد ان الحرب
وان طالت لا يمكن ان توقف شغف الناس
للثقافه والمعرفه دوله عبد العزيز المقالح
رد اعتبار لهذه
الهامه الكبيره جدا لما قدمته من ابداعات
في سبيل اسراء الثقافه اليمنيه حقيقه ما
جرى في هذا المعرض هو عرس ثقافي كبير جدا
تشهده هذه المدينه وكل المدن الحاضره
والثقافيه
اكثر من 25 داره نشرن عربيه ومحليه واقسام
للتراث والثقافه احتواها معرض مارب الثاني
للكتاب الذي شهد اقبالا كبيرا في يومه
الاول
اقبالن جسد الحياه الطبيعيه والسلامه في
مدينه تصدرت عناوين الحرب خلال الفتره
الماضيه استطعنا التغلب على العراقيين كان
هناك صعوبه في اصول بعض الناشرين الذين
ارسلوا كتبهم لتعرض عبر التوكيلات لدور
نشر المحليه هناك مشاركه اكثر من 30 مكتبه
دار نشر هناك الكتاب الالكتروني حاضر هذه
المره لاول مره في معرض هذا دليل على ما
تشهده من تنميه ومن حراك ثقافي ومعرفه
كبير معرض الكتاب للمره الثانيه واصرار من
مارب على انتصار السلامه على انتصار العلم
على انتصار الثقافه همم عمل عظيم فعلا ااه
ان تصير مارب على نشر الوعي في اجواء هذه
يمثل معرض الكتاب في مارب متنفسا للثقافه
والعلم لملايين النازحين واملا في احلال
السلام وعوده الحياه
سنظل نحفر في الجدار اما فتحنا فجوه
للنوري او متنا على وجه الجدار هكذا مارب
تتكلم بلسان المقالح في معرضها الثاني
للكتاب محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب